yesterday Tesla founder Elon Musk
revealed that his company lost 700
million dollars last quarter yeah some
analysts say Tesla could run out of
money by the end of 2018 now Tesla's
financial woes are partly due to delays
and shipping their model 3 electric car
that people ordered two years ago with a
$1,000 deposit but to turn around the
company thinks they can turn this whole
thing around with their latest product
check it out
the Tesla TBD will be coming out in 2024
assuming no delays and you can reserve
yours for only $2,000 is it a new
electric car it could be it's one of
those Power Packs that will get my home
off the grid is it is it a condenser
that makes clean drinking water out of
moisture in the atmosphere why don't you
give us two thousand dollars and find
out in 2020 for the Tesla TBD it could
be anything including a fast and easy
cash flow infusion that eliminates the
need to create more stock because that
would they loop the value of Tesla's
existing shares
I want one
you